foreign
[Laughter]
[Music]
the far right I would love to see a
response a violent response or to to see
something they can use as in the
argument in the future so I I must go
there and make sure that people are calm
people are in the best shape know how to
how to respond to their feelings to make
sure there's no violence so so it's a
responsibility
which I need to do if I want to prove
to prove them wrong at least
do you think they are killers do you
think
you think like a crime religion right
and that's the dangerous message
[Music]
we're not planning to change your
Society we just want our space and we
want our values to be respected like we
respect other values and we respect
other a group of peoples here in the
society